the marriage of Megan Markel into the
British Royal Family was celebrated as
progress a national triumph of diversity
and inclusivity but hidden behind the
positivity her arrival has also exposed
an underbelly of unpleasant online abuse
the majority of the country proud to
have her as their new Duchess but her
impact has revealed an uncomfortable
truth about us too
[Music]
a year ago we saw a Dutch s determined
to do things differently we've got to
get you all married
we've watched her adjust to this more
traditional life through her charity
projects we've seen more than just a
hint of the former actress like these
women I'm passionate about food and
cooking as a way of strengthening
communities and a woman not afraid to
break away from the norm
throughout Prince Harry has been there
for support as Megan has attracted
incredible levels of adoration but also
plenty of negative press just months
into her life as a royal unattributed
briefings from inside the palace and
negative headlines started to appear the
tone had shifted so when was it that you
first met Megan I met her when I was
organizing the global gift ala PR
consultant Nick I'd worked with Megan on
a charity event in London before she met
Harry he thinks the actress turned
Duchess could be lost in translation
she's very passionate
it's a moment you're ambitious you want
to do the best you want to be the best
and want to get to the best you can be I
mean you know this is somebody who's
just entered the royal family who is
probably working quadruple e as hard as
she was when she's learning scripts for
seats so she's actually put herself in a
position where it's not an easy life you
know there's far more easy things to do
than their showbiz baby shower in New
York really split opinion as some felt
it was too flashy for a member of the
monarchy this is her life you know her
life has been as a celebrity for many
more years and she has been the princess
so actually for her and for everybody
else this is just normal life the
problem is there is a big difference
between her celebrity and royal life
with everything that she does now being
picked over by a much bigger
international audience her decision to
write on bananas that will be given to
sex workers in Bristol was one of those
moments that attracted as much criticism
as praise especially on social media a
member of the royal family who who
from this country who isn't from there
same cultural group no we should be much
more accepting and and welcome that and
the royal family is engaging and
changing as as the world is I do I do
think it's appalling some of it and
should be stopped modernizers are
usually divisive figures especially
within the British royal family but
Megan's natural Americanisms there is no
better time than to really continue to
shine a light on women feeling empowered
her tendency to break with royal
tradition and for some even her
ethnicity have led to a sinister trend
of abuse emerging online search on any
of the big social media platforms and
you will find millions of posts about
the Royals right now with their baby on
the way the Duke and Duchess of Sussex
are the biggest hits but Megan has also
become the main target for trolls to
understand the lows as well as the highs
of Megan's new role we asked the experts
at Storyful a social media research
agency to dig deeper into this trend of
online abuse so our tools allow us to
observe and analyze across multiple
platforms by analyzing the most
derogatory terms they uncovered
thousands of offensive posts or
mainstream social media and more
secretive fringe platforms social media
platforms have become this virtual soap
box where people can more widely share
their views about the monarchy while
other members of the royal family are
certainly not immune from criticism I've
never seen it become so vicious and
personal as it does around the Duchess
of Sussex there were multiple pages and
profiles across mainstream platforms
like Facebook like YouTube like Twitter
Instagram all seemingly set up with the
single purpose or the major purpose of
abusing Megan Merkel of making false
claims about her of maligning her
character and claiming that she was a
grifter who had gotten her way into the
royal family by way of hoaxes
these were among the 20 most prolific
Twitter accounts that use popular
abusive terms like maggot Markel and
makes it you can see some of the more
common words being used in these
conversations are things like moon bong
Charlotte and Duchess Duchess of
deception a few of the accounts are from
overseas but the majority are based
right here in the UK using offensive
hashtags about her race and claiming
she's a social climber our report shows
some of these accounts have thousands of
followers there are a lot of people who
questioned her bona fides who questioned
her legitimacy there's all sorts of
racist commentary about Markel and
thereafter people seem to be directed to
the private groups where there's the
potential for more extreme discussions
our research also showed that nearly a
quarter of tweets mentioning Megan
contain angry content and that's
compared to only three percent of tweets
referencing the Duchess of Cambridge we
showed the research to Bonnie Grimm who
worked for one of the American TV
networks on the day of the Royal Wedding
what is your immediate reaction to what
we've uncovered completely shocked I
knew about the abuse directed at Megan
but I didn't know the level of it the
intensity of it they're just it's just
it's sick I assumed that there would be
a level of racist abuse because you you
do I've never seen this before
or heard this before type in Megan or
Duchess of Sussex and the extent of the
racist abuse is painfully clear our
research found multiple posts featuring
pictures of bananas and monkeys in
reference to her mixed-race heritage and
shockingly her unborn child is also the
subject of racist abuse with malicious
posts about the baby's ethnicity
I feel the embryonic kicking of feminism
a far-fetched conspiracy has also grown
around her pregnancy with hashtags like
moon bump and Megan Markel is not
pregnant
videos like this one that I posted on
Twitter from International Women's Day
she's a real person used to apparently
confirm that her baby bump isn't real
there was this ongoing scrutiny of her
and her ethnicity always inevitable it
was something that Megan acknowledged
when they got engaged
of course it's disheartening you know
it's it's a shame that that is the
climate in this world to focus that much
on that or that that would be
discriminatory in that sense but I think
you know at the end of the day I'm
really just proud of Who I am and where
I come from and we have never put any
focus on that princess tessie of
Luxembourg has some idea what that
attention is like she was from an
ordinary family and served in the
military before she married into
Luxembourg's monarchy in 2006 my family
suffered greatly when I married into the
family my little cousin she needed to
change school twice my twin brother was
incredibly bullied at work still is
today my sister my parents suffered my
oldest brother doesn't talk to me
anymore because of that because it was
too much for him to handle and that was
when I married him and then when I got
divorced oh my gosh the same it's just
you know what I have learned is you can
never please everyone and some people
will just like to talk bad about you a
person that went to school with me
literally wrote me an email got my email
from somewhere four years ago and wrote
me and said I'm sorry I wrote that about
you I know it's not true but I need to
feed my children
[Applause]
she's now concentrating on her charity
work good evening everyone
using her social media to promote more
positive messages including support for
the Dutchess of Sussex and I think why I
did it and why I stand up for her and
for a lot of other people as well is
because my children read these things
and I don't want my children to grow up
in such an environment this is not a
society I want my kids to grow up in
dealing with the spotlight is nothing
new for the Windsors and they've all had
to adapt to this new media age even if
it is their newest member who's been
targeted the most one of the reasons
that the palace launched their social
media guidelines was because they were
increasingly finding that Megan's
supporters and Megan critics were using
their official sites to publicly trade
insults and the Megan supporters can be
just as brutal and threatening at times
towards other online users and
journalists who they think are not 100
percent behind their Duchess I don't
look at who never look at say Twitter no
sorry no despite Megan's saying that she
doesn't look and Harry claiming that
social media is now more addictive for
children than drugs and alcohol they've
launched their new Instagram account
already they have used it thanked their
fans for launching the hashtag global
Sussex baby shower and giving to their
favorite charities words like diapers
may be a suggestion that Megan is more
in control than it would appear she's
been very smart to get ahead get out
front we're gonna shape this narrative
when it's time for our baby to be born
we're going to show you this baby's
picture we're gonna share these pictures
with you we're gonna have this baby when
we're ready to have this baby and we're
gonna have this baby where we want to
have this baby
with their baby too very soon they're
doing everything they can to take
control of their privacy and the media
phenomenon that their new family will
become it is about the clash of cultures
and I think it's just us getting our
heads around the fact that this is a
beautiful mixed-race intelligent
articulate American woman is now part of
our establishment they can create
something I think new for us they they
can create a high profile couple within
the matrix of the royal family who can
do good their 21st century Royals
anything to show us how to be in a
multicultural international diverse
world and that's their purpose so while
there will always be others in the
palace with more influence in our social
media age this American Duchess is
shaping how we view the most British of
institutions